well you may be looking for summer camps
for your younger kids you're probably
looking for ways to keep your teen
occupied so as summer foot traffic
starts to ramp up in business here in
the valley eight news now reporter
Victoria Saha tells us they are looking
to fill the gap
grouchy John's coffee is often busy but
it's about to get even busier as summer
is right around the corner yeah I'm here
from early in the morning when we open
until late at night owner JJ Wiley finds
himself filling in more than usual as
help is hard to come by normally you
know my in my email inbox is full and it
just didn't this time for a shop usually
run by mostly teens Wiley says he would
consider hiring as young as 14. now that
I'm getting kind of desperate for help I
might have to 16 year old Sophia Bedard
is working her very first summer shift
at grouchy John's I'm so bad about
spending money that's why I need a job
so is there an art to scooping ice cream
just pull from the right side after that
just pull again from the left over at
Dylan's Family Ice Cream in North Las
Vegas the number of applicants seem to
be melting away we have so many people
that come in and out all the time and
maybe one out of 100 asking for hiring
owner Cheryl Ortega finds yourself
behind the counter to keep the doors
open but I definitely would be okay with
hiring a 14 year old if it meant meeting
the staffing needs for my company not
only do these young teens get valuable
lessons about work ethic at a young age
they also get a delicious sweet treat
making that connection with the customer
making them feel comfortable making them
feel you know happy to to be here and to
to get a good treat is a bonus extra
pocket money on some ice cream what I
would do to be a teen again Victoria
Saha 8 News Now